why do people watch eSports because we
like watching exciting matches between
people who are good we want to see the
guys who are masters on these champions
who can make situations happen out of
nothing at all and just light a spark
that consumes the entire game by making
a single out and that's what you're
going to get to watch upwards
[Music]
over the last decade League of Legends
has pushed gaming into a different
stratosphere with its popularity helping
legitimize video games in the mainstream
media and it's impressive competitive
scene paving the way for future eSports
in 2017 the League of Legends World
Championship grand final took place in
Beijing's bird nest Stadium the same
stadium that's set to host the 2022
Winter Olympics the massive crowds that
filled the stands paled in comparison to
the individuals who tuned it online
making it the most watched video game
event in history this year world's is
heading to South Korea on the biggest
stage eSports has ever known world's is
the biggest League of Legends
competition in the world bar none
period no exceptions go with the worlds
for me was one of the biggest
achievements of my life it's still
something I look back and be like you
know what separates me from a lot of the
other players I went to worlds worlds is
such a Herculean task for these guys
they have to go and as soon as they've
grinded out everything that they needed
you to win summer finals now they go to
like a boot camp to get ready for world
and worlds is you know such a long event
over all these different weeks like
getting there then the real work begins
so it is like crazy what these guys go
for and yet that is that is the goal for
them right is to go to Worlds and to
hopefully one day win it I feel like the
fans once a year they get to rally
around their nationality or like their
regional pride every single region comes
in with their own type of strategy what
they think is the best strategy that
they can come up with through a year of
preparation they come in and a test to
see if the strategy is the best against
the other strategies in the world teams
that do well in worlds are just I mean
that's what people remember for years
and years to come
SKT Rox Tigers in one of the greatest
five-game series ever played at legal in
league of legends let alone at Worlds
that famous ash arrow that prays shot
out cross map and hit Duke who was
trying to recall back to save the game
the places is sold out absolutely packed
the arrow starts to go across the map
and all of Madison Square Garden fall
silent
world's is the largest celebration for
league of legends internationally and
it's a prestigious milestone for those
who make it there but the world stage
wasn't built overnight today we're
taking a look back at the history behind
that legacy considering the growth of
worlds is a crazy journey you know back
in season 1 back in 2011 we did it in
partnership with dreamhack shows over in
Janka ping
they kind of bring your own PC festival
we didn't even host it ourselves and
there was honestly question whether it
should even be put online whether people
would want to watch it on streaming and
you know fortunately we did and saw
hundreds thousands of people show up
which blew the minds of a lot of people
here cuz I was like oh people wanted to
see this played seriously
in 2012 we went to the Galen Center and
we saw you know we filled out a
professional style basketball arena then
2013 went to the Staples Center one of
the most iconic venues in North America
and sold that out within minutes and
delivered an amazing show so we went to
Korea we sold out a World Cup state we
went to Germany we sold out the
mercedes-benz arena and we went back to
China we did the bird's nest like one of
the most iconic stadiums in all of the
world this is the place that held the
opening ceremony for the Chinese Olympic
Games like this is a place that has
national importance in China and it sold
out instantly flowing over to Sweden to
shoutcast the League of Legends World
Championship for 2011 at that time was
called season 1 and it was cool because
we definitely didn't know who was going
to win like now it's like okay it's
Korea but maybe China but back in the
day was it was really exciting to try to
figure out who is actually the best
North America versus EU is always super
heated that rivalry is always gonna be
there whenever our teams meet each other
you've got the Koreans who are like the
nineties bowls or the current version of
the the New England Patriots right that
just they seem to win everything is like
who's going to actually beat these guys
the history of North American waltz
unfortunately has been failure for the
most part it seems like we send good
teams and we have great players but they
just never convert any of their success
when they have to play against
especially the big Korean teams all the
big Chinese teams so even some of the
big European teams have given us a lot
of struggles over the years
semi-finals taken down the North
American champions cloud nine
and it looks like Samsung Galaxy will be
moving on to the semifinals at Madison
Square Garden
[Applause]
this is the first time North America has
made a semi-final at Worlds in seven
years the achievement itself like just
as making semi-finals is already massive
and the fact that I went through a
Korean team together who have long been
considered the most single dominant
region to ever play the game and that
has been true at every World
Championships except this one like that
short part that world's in and of itself
is insane for any North American team to
do it does validate that the region is
extremely strong and like can compete no
longer can other regions disrespect the
West or consider them not viable title
contenders when it comes to future
international events I think no matter
what the strength of the West from both
EU and na and their representation in
this event has already proven that come
ms icon world's next year that these are
teams that you must be prepared for
Invictus gaming the last hope of the LPL
battle against fnatic the first world
champions hoping to be the latest the
last hope of Europe the last
with the growing success of events like
worlds it's clearer than ever the
eSports are here to stay earlier this
year was reported by Forbes that brand
investment had increased 48 percent
year-over-year and that by 2020 revenue
could reach over 1.6 billion dollars so
what could a billion-dollar future look
like for eSports I got a chance to be a
part of a conversation with the you know
the Olympic Committee about their
understanding of the sports community
and these sports committee wanting to
understand what the IOC is about I was
most concerned about protecting the
perception that in some way eSports
needed the IOC I think there's value
that the IOC definitely brings to
eSports and these sports brings to the
IOC but if they there can't be a
marriage where things are serve the
community of eSports then I don't think
it should have it currently I think
there are games that are leading higher
than what the Olympics will give them
you know League of Legends World
Championship the dota ti these things
are gigantic and already kind of pulled
themselves up by their bootstraps
without needing anymore it would be
amazing to be in the Olympics more
eyeballs are great but I don't think
it's a necessity at this time it's not
as important to me about whether we
catch the World Cup or whether we beat
the Olympics or whether we're in the
Olympics or whether or not for me it's
just about how many fans can we go out
and how many can we show a great time
and for me that's what Worlds is really
about it's the pinnacle of competition
it's the best time of year for all of
our fans it's the must-see can't-miss
shows and so you know as long as we're
kind of tapping into that spirit you
know we'll see where the viewership ends
up and I just trust it'll be in pretty
good shape
thank you for joining us on our
eight-part League of Legends mae series
exploring all the reasons why league of
Legends is one of the most interesting
stories in gaming
[Music]
you